michael thomas
who set the single season record for
receptions easily and was the single
season last year receiving yardage
leader
the oddsmakers have made him the
favorite to lead the league in receiving
yards again so let's play a little fill
in the blank receiver edition we'll
start with chris michael thomas is the
best what chris
i i think would i really look at it and
obviously he's in the conversation for
best receiver in football but what i can
definitively say where he is the
absolute best
is he's the best slot receiver in the
nfl in my opinion and you know that's
really what he is he's a big slot
receiver and he's a good route runner
and of course because of you know his
physicality and size and length he is
fearless over the middle so sean payton
can devise plays for him that you know
you couldn't devise for a smaller wide
receiver and do things like that you
know not let alone his good route
running his size he gets out of gets out
of the brakes well and all that but he's
got unbelievable hands he could care
less who's around him and he's just got
great feel what you need is a slot
receiver too you got zone coverage you
got to figure out what hole to sit in
and what to do and be on the same page
as the quarterback so
that's where i truly think i could say
he's absolutely the best he's the best
slot receiver in the game in my opinion
i would say he's the best competitor
among skilled players in football right
now
and you know the reason that i say that
is that when i watch him
i think he is a more competitive chris
carter and i always thought that chris
carter was like the sickest
uh almost michael jordan type demeaning
everybody
to get the ball and to and to you know
he knew what it took to be great and
what it takes to win and i'm not saying
demeaning really in a negative way i'm
saying
i am going to win
everybody understand that and if i have
to you know climb all over you to do it
i'm going to do it
and to me
not only physically competitive because
on 50 50 balls as sean payton told me
this winner he makes some 70 30 balls
on so on 50 50 balls he's gonna win
those but also it's just the mental part
of him and going back with devonta
parker
like you know almost flicking him off
his shoulder like he's a mosquito you
know and hey dude you're not in my
league and again a lot of us will look
at that and say hey hey mike you know i
mean just relax relax about it
because he lives it every day
i'm gonna go way down memory lane here i
had a flash in my mind of wendell davis
when he was at lsu do you guys remember
wendell davis guy who blew out both
patel attendants on the old green cement
at veterans stadium on the set both at
the same time trying to jump for a ball
anyway there was a game at lsu once
where everybody knew he was getting the
ball and and they kept throwing it to
him every play and they couldn't do
anything about it and that's what
michael thomas is michael thomas is the
best at making the catch when everybody
in the stadium knows the ball is coming
to him the defense can't do anything
about it it's inevitable it happens and
he makes the catch even when the entire
you can tell the defense it's going to
michael thomas he's still going to make
the catch and i think that kind of
blends together what both of you are
saying and that's why he's so reliable
in that saints offense because he's
their best weapon by far becomes
interesting with emmanuel sanders there
this year to take a little heat off of
michael thomas but even without sanders
everyone knows it's going to thomas he
still finds a way to get open and finds
a way to make the catch all right the
most reliable gotta have it receiver is
who chris
well you know i think we know you're
gonna say michael thomas there after
just your answer we kind of know that
because that's basically what you just
said he's the most reliable guy and i
think legitimately listen for the
exercise michael thomas what is a big
third and five or third and six i'm not
so sure he's not the guy i would want to
have to throw to to me it's between him
and i'm gonna pick this guy for for for
a little variety is deandre hopkins
i mean to me he goes down for a lot of
the same reasons we're talking about
michael thomas you know that's a great
saying what peter king just said there
yeah it's it's 70 30 balls they're not
50 50 balls and that goes with deandre
hopkins it's the same thing i don't know
if i've seen better hands in football
the last few years than deandre hopkins
catching the ball in traffic with people
all around him i mean hey we talk about
yeah michael thomas we know the saints
want to go to him hey at least they
throw the ball to alvin kamara and jared
cook and do that like we know in houston
when it was a big play it was like who
the hell cares who the other receivers
are on the field number four is gonna
look for number ten and that's what he's
gonna do and even if he's double covered
he's going to hold the ball and go i'll
wait for number 10 to get open from the
double coverage so to me he is the
ultimate gotta have it wide receiver uh
nook as they call him deandre hopkins
look i'm gonna take uh i'm gonna take
jarvis landry the cleveland browns and
everybody will say well okay good
receiver whatever
you know jarvis landry to me is such an
uber competitive guy on in michael
thomas's
range
and
when i really learned the most about
jarvis landry i was on a trip a few
years ago on one of these
you know nfl trips over to england uh
and end to end to uh we went to scotland
as well but there was a bunch of players
on the trip and one night
i'm on a bus
sitting next to jarvis landry
and we're on the bus for probably about
an hour
and he and and it was a i can tell the
story now but at the moment he was
talking about how can i get the dolphins
to pay me how can i get the dolphins to
believe in me how do i and so i mean
that night it was almost like the veins
were coming out of his neck and it
wasn't just about the money it was about
i am one of the greatest and i am just
afraid that my career is going to go by
without people seeing that and it didn't
matter he had a lot of catches he was
kind of stuck in in miami at that point
but
i just think and i watch him play and i
just think of a guy who just
wants it so bad and wants everybody to
know how bad he wants it
and you know chris i i was thinking
deandre hopkins right out of the gates
because of the reality that there was no
one else in houston to throw the ball to
in those key moments in those crunch
moments he's the guy that needed to get
it but uh yeah i'll go with hopkins for
that all right one more real quickly the
best complimentary receiver duo is who
chris
well i'm gonna you know this might be
captain obvious here but i think it's
you gotta go with mike evans and chris
godwin down in tampa i mean you got one
guy that's six five and can you know run
deep and catch 50 50 jump balls then you
know and chris godwin you got the guy
that's you know arguably one of the best
slot wide receivers in the game and
statistically i think he had one of the
best years in the slot so that's a great
combo when you have the big guy that's
fast that could work downfield and then
you got the other guy who can do all the
short to intermediate work uh to me
that's a very nice compliment uh with
those two there
you know i'm gonna i'm gonna surprise
you a little bit i'm gonna take one for
the future okay and i'm gonna say it's
going to be cortland sutton and jerry
judy and again
i know they haven't played football yet
i get it together i get it but i just
think these two guys they're similar
receivers the other bigger guys and they
both are incredibly productive in my
opinion you watch sutton and judy and
look chris you're absolutely right if
you hadn't taken those two guys i would
have so i'm scrambling mentally and i
can't wait to see
judy and sutton together
and the spirit of the phrase
complimentary would suggest different
skill sets but i'm going to throw that
out the window because if you guys
aren't going to mention tyreek hill and
sammy watkins i will i'll take them if
they're left i'll take them and i'll run
not nearly as fast as they can but i'll
run nevertheless
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports